bonjour à tous alors c'est officiel et
record pourra bien de saison 5
et ce qui est officiel aussi c'est que
ce sera la dernière je vais expliquer
pourquoi c'est la fin des records parce
qu'on pose beaucoup la question c'est la
fin des records parce que d'un point de
vue narratif on arrive au bout de
l'histoire
la fin était prévue depuis longtemps et
là on est tout proche de ça et puis est
ce qui me motive aussi c'est de décider
on décide compte s'arrête et donc la fin
des records sera celle qu'on a on a
imaginé la série s'arrêtera la dernière
séquence des records sera une séquence
créé en sachant que derrière il n'y en
aura plus quand on fait ça les délais je
pense que c'est un luxe puisque ya
beaucoup de séries qui sont annulés par
les par les chaînes il n'est pas
question de ça pour l'instant évidemment
mais je pense que après avoir été arrêté
pendant deux ans et puis on est reparti
en est reparti je pense encore plus fort
qu'avant
hélas ce moment de s'arrêter dans ces
conditions là pour pas être frustré et
pour que la fin soit imaginé comme une
fin donc voilà déjà
ensuite ça fera quand la série sera à
l'antenne ça fera huit ans qu'on
travaille tous sur corp et je pense
qu'il est temps de passer à autre chose
ça fera quasiment un tiers de ma vie
passée sur leur corp
c'est un projet qui me tient beaucoup à
coeur france que les gens qui suivent la
série q le début le savent j'ai encore
beaucoup d'histoires à vous raconter
mais je vous la raconterai dans d'autres
contextes
voilà je pense que c'est le moment j'en
suis convaincu et et j'espère que vous
profiterez du final de cette série mais
les records pas toujours été un
laboratoire pour nous et c'est pour ça
que il ya une deuxième partie à cette
vidéo on a toujours essayé de faire de
mieux en mieux avec le même budget qui
est pas énorme mais nous on a pris comme
un commun comme un jeu on fait comme un
challenge
on essaye de faire de mieux en mieux je
pense qu'on y arrive et la saison 4 est
la meilleure de loin c'est la plus
réussie et elle a coûté un peu plus cher
de saison 4 on arrive en saison 5
et on n'est pas menacé
on n'est pas on n'est pas en train de ne
pas pouvoir la faire mais on a besoin de
vous on a un partenaire qui n'est plus
là donc le financement pour la première
fois est inférieur à ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à maintenant c'est pas énormément
qui nous manquent mais il nous manque
de quoi la faire une condition qu'on
veut la faire donc on a créé une page
hull pour que ceux qui veulent nous aide
c'est une page qui nous ressemble le
concept de tout ça c'est que comme la
série s'arrête on vous propose de partir
avec un souvenir avec un bout de cette
série avec un objet que vous avez vus à
l'écran que vous avez vus à l'image qui
a appartenu un plein de personnages
différence atteint vous verrez ce qu'il
ya beaucoup de choses énormément de
choses on propose de partir avec un
souriant de la série et en échange nous
on peut bosser dans des conditions un
peu plus confortable avoir plus de jours
faire plus d'effets spéciaux pouvoir
continuer d'aller en augmentant la
qualité
cette page bull pour moi c'est une sorte
de grande braderie
la série s'arrête et chacun aura le
souvenir qui veut de cette aventure chez
lui il ya aussi d'aider des objets plus
classique des choses plus classiques
mais voilà on n'est pas en train de
mourir c'est pas la fin de la série on
va faire la saison 5
quoi qu'il arrive mais il faut qu'on
continue à pouvoir faire et record dont
les conditions dans lesquelles on l'a
fait jusqu'à maintenant
donc on a besoin de vous pour ça on
tourne en octobre la série sera diffusée
comme d'habitude un peu à la bourre
parce que forcément on est branché pour
le montage des effets spéciaux mais on
aime ça
aucune carte du hero corp donc là le
format va changer encore ce sera du 25
minutes
c'est un retour aux sources on s'est dit
que une saison en format différent ce
n'est peut-être une bonne manière de moi
je sais pas en fait mais voilà le final
de la saison sera différent qui sera
j'espère
calcul r mais ce sera différent dans sa
construction
je vous en dis pas plus si vous voulez
nous donner un coup de main allez-y la
page s'affiche et juste à la fin de
cette vidéo
à très bientôt à tous
mais savez vous pouvez compter sur moi
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il n'est pas aimé
ça c'est fini
ce genre d'ambiance ça me donne vraiment
chaud dans ma culotte